On Tuesday, November 8th, this country will make one of the most important,...
...the most important,...
...the most important decisions in its history.
You have a chance,...
...you have an obligation,...
...to be a part of that decision.
You might think it's not important.
You might think you're not important.
But that's not true.
And the only way we can prove that to you is by having lots of famous people...
...repeating how important...
...important,...
...how important it is.
Register.
Vote.
We can save the day...
...for our children,...
...for our communities,...
...for America.
All it takes is all of us.
All of us.
We can not pretend both sides are equally unfavorable.
We can't say one vote doesn't matter.
Your vote matters.
It affects everything.
Not just the presidency...
...but the Senate,...
...the House,...
...your local officials,...
...immigration,...
Immigrant.
...student debt,...
...commonsense gun laws,...
...the Supreme Court.
See, this isn't just an election, it's a tipping point...
...for the country,...
...for the world,...
...for your world.
If you don't know how or where to register...
...go to SaveTheDay.vote.
SaveTheDay.vote